Speaker 1: It's great to welcome and Newman
to the program today, author and columnist,
and we are going to be talking about vaccines,
operation, warp speed.
There are really so many things to discuss.
And so maybe, maybe to start Operation Warp
Speed.
I interviewed a Republican strategist recently
and she very adamantly pointed to Operation
Warp Speed and Donald Trump as the reason
why so many vaccines are now available.
I asked exactly what Trump did.
She didn't really have anything to tell me.
So let's start there.
I mean, what exactly did Operation Warp Speed
achieve that wouldn't otherwise have been
achieved?
What was Trump's role in that?
Speaker 6: Yeah, Trump set this up as instead
of opening up the market to the world and
trying to make these formulas accessible to
everyone.
He kind of made this pool of money that incentivized
six individual companies.
We're talking ten billion dollars, probably
up to 18 billion at this point.
And these six companies received a huge amount
of money as well as exclusivity.
So they were paid, say, one hundred and ninety
one point nine, five billion dollars for research.
Yes.
But then also an additional amount for vaccines.
And those vaccines, that payment was guaranteed,
whether the vaccines worked or not.
So what it did was pull a whole bunch of minds
in one place and dump tons of money into them
with this concept that a free market, which,
of course, is not free.
Right.
That's like the perfect example of a form
of socialism.
Yeah.
What would accelerate the development of these
vaccines?
Meanwhile, the Mornay research was already
being worked on by the National Institutes
of Health.
So like all pharmaceutical innovation, this
was grandly subsidized not just monetarily,
but also research wise by by federal entities.
Speaker 1: Now, I've I've read I read things
that are essentially it seems as though both
can't possibly be true.
On the one hand, I'm reading about how the
pharmaceutical companies are not releasing
the formula for manufacturing vaccine so that
other countries could just start producing
them right away rather than waiting on the
supply flow from the companies that are producing
them.
Now, at the same time, I read that, for example,
in twenty twenty, I don't remember if it was
Pfizer, Moderna or both said that they were
open sourcing the recipe if someone wants
to produce it.
But it does seem as though there is significant
infrastructure and fixed costs necessary to
do that, where maybe it's not actually going
to get vaccines to people more quickly.
If a new country wants to start manufacturing,
what is the truth about that?
Speaker 6: Yeah, it's it's really hard to
pass because the IP patent special manufacturing
categories also there's a category, undisclosed
information like since the Reagan era, pharmaceutical
companies have employed a whole raft of special
categories that are covered and set up to
protect their profit, basically.
And so even though Moderna last fall, I believe
it was in October, as you mentioned, said,
sure enough, our patent is we won't enforce
our patent is what they said.
Yes, it was a great PR play for them, but
it basically didn't do anything because there
are these other layers of intellectual property
enforcement that can be employed whenever
anyone gets involved.
And, you know, I talked to Dean Baker for
the article that I wrote for The Baffler.
And Baker, who is an expert on intellectual
property, said, you know, they there are many
ways that the government could make this information
available.
So intellectual property is being used to
cover not just the formula for the recipes,
but also these techniques and manufacturing
processes that really could just be disclosed
as easily as any recipe.
I mean, there's nothing that prevents manufacturers
of pharmaceuticals from sharing that information
as well, except that they're getting ridiculously
rich.
Speaker 1: Now, as a practical question, I'll
give you one situation that's happening in
Argentina where I was born and have a lot
of family.
Argentina is primarily using the Sputnik vaccine,
which many love because it's open source.
And now Argentina has announced that they
are going to start manufacturing it.
And some of my uncles are very, very happy
who are loyalists to the current administration.
But when I actually look into the details,
the ramp, if it's even true.
Right, let's assume it's true that Argentina
will start manufacturing this.
If it's even true, the ramp up process will
take so long that.
By the time Argentina could be making any
of these Sputnik vaccines, Argentina won't
need them and it will really be used to take
something that's open source and sell it to
even poorer countries in South America to
make money in Argentina.
So is like is is that good or is the scale
up process really even possible to do quickly
enough that it wouldn't just make sense to
get an order in for vaccines rather than look
at making them oneself?
I'm just thinking out loud here.
Speaker 6: Well, like anything else, it's
distribution and information, right?
That's what hinders the the sharing of any
kind of material.
And so distribution access to the APIs or
the active pharmaceutical ingredients, ingredients,
the technology and the materials could be
better negotiated.
Right.
There's no central power that is making sure
that the countries who need this technology
and these formulas are going to get them.
And that's the real problem.
I mean, there are a number of organizations
that at the very beginning said, all right,
this is going to be big.
And as a globe, we need to work together to
to make sure that everyone has the same access,
that medical ethics is employed in the distribution
of these very necessary medicines.
And obviously, Bill Gates came in.
Who's playing this unnecessarily large role
in public health, health around the globe
with an extraordinary amount of goodwill.
And he basically co-opted the system to make
it so that everything was run through large
pharmaceutical companies.
And so here we are with this crazy bottleneck.
I also want to emphasize that in other countries
around the world, there are other issues I.
I don't want to take India's Modi off the
table as a stumbling block.
People are making bad decisions all around
the world.
We also know that on other continents, including
our own, there are corrupt governments and
corrupt politicians.
And so I think on the whole, as a as a globe,
we were completely.
Unprepared for what was coming our way and
we never had a strong voice, the United States
never demonstrated any kind of leadership,
and certainly during the Trump administration,
we were incredibly isolationist in how our
politics were discussed and and and mediated.
So I think that America first isolationism
also put us very much behind.
So it's not just the fact that these vaccines
are hard to get a hold of because of patents
and these layers of IP protection.
But it's that also the you know, just the
the understanding of we need to work together
to make sure this happens just isn't there.
Speaker 1: When it comes to the dramatic increase
in actual vaccinations that has taken place
over the last few few months, was this naturally
going to happen no matter who was president,
or does the Biden administration get credit
for what they've what they've done?
Speaker 6: I think that's a good question,
I think certainly Biden coming in removed
a lot of the animosity.
He's been clear with messaging.
I think there was so much misinformation,
whether that's by design in our current media
landscape or just an administration that really
didn't care about the rest of the world dying,
didn't care about the disparity in the United
States, where blacks and people of color were
unable to access vaccine doses.
So I think definitely it's a change and tone
and tenor a lot.
But, yeah, pharmaceuticals are going to pharmaceutical
and they are working nondisclosure contracts
with countries around the world.
That's a huge incentive for them.
Not only have they kind of recouped their
their reputation with all of this, they have
designed the vaccine, but they they're also
making bank.
Speaker 1: When you think, oh, let's talk
about that a little bit.
Is it that profitable to do this?
And I again, I'm you read so many things that
point in different directions with Pfizer,
for example.
From what I've seen, the entire vaccination
program seems to have affected revenue by
about one point eight percent.
Now, it's such a big company that one point
eight percent is a lot of dollars.
But in terms of year over year changes, it
doesn't seem dramatic.
So what how should we be thinking of that
as a profit center?
Speaker 6: We should be thinking long term
because that's what the farmers are doing.
They're they're looking at the fact that we've
got strains coming.
Not only do we have, you know, a huge percentage
of the world that hasn't received a vaccine
yet.
Right.
They're thinking when the crisis is over,
they can raise the cost of each dose to the
normal one twenty five, one hundred and fifty
range instead of the 18 to thirty four that
they're getting each dose now for
Speaker 1: the possible future variant booster's,
for example,
Speaker 6: but also for the possible variant
booster's, not only just getting the vaccine
out to the globe, but then following up.
And this might be an annual thing for us,
just like the flu.
Right.
We're not sure how long we're going to remain
have to remain on this vaccination schedule.
But also the entire vaccine industry has been
changed by covid-19 in the past.
Big Pharma wasn't very interested in it because
it was, you know, low cost.
A lot of generics were being used.
And a quick aside here is that India manufactures
80 percent of the drugs that we use in the
United States.
So when we talk about manufacturing elsewhere,
it's not like Big Pharma manufactures its
own drugs anyway.
They find that out quite often.
And secondly, 70 percent of the materials
for manufacturing drugs come from China.
So the drug supply chain has already been
precarious for several decades.
So the vaccine industry never really appealed
to pharma because it wasn't a big money maker.
You get your smallpox vaccine and that's it.
They prefer the very expensive drugs that
have to be taken every day, say cancer drugs
are rare diseases and that's where their big
money is.
And so what Operation Warp Speed did was dump
a whole bunch of money into the vaccine industry
and make it very profitable and busto, a crazy
amount of goodwill on these companies.
Speaker 1: Last thing I want to talk about,
when we think about the trajectory for vaccinating
the world, then we know that there are countries
that we're talking twenty twenty two.
We're talking twenty, twenty three different
estimates.
One says twenty, twenty four.
Until you really have full vaccination in
some parts of the world.
Ultimately, will the bottleneck be a manufacturing
and distribution bottleneck?
Will it be an intellectual property bottleneck?
What is the one thing that if it changed,
could move that date up?
Speaker 6: Countries are so different, our
relationships with them are so different.
It's really hard to say, OK, I believe that
it's probably going to be the distribution
and the manufacturing and those special manufacturing
techniques.
And that's just a lack of coordination.
But that's not to say like intellectual property
law is kind of the umbrella term for a whole
bunch of things.
Right.
So if companies are willing to share their
drug patents but not willing to share special
manufacturing techniques, it's the same thing.
They're causing other manufacturing entities
out there from getting up to speed on distributing
this.
Right.
Speaker 1: It would be like if I have a really
complicated soufflé, I could give you the
list of ingredients.
But the technique is that what I do with the
ingredients is essentially just as important.
Right, exactly.
We've been speaking with Ann Newman, author
and columnist, and I so appreciate your time
today to talk about this really important
topic.
Speaker 6: Yeah, I agree.
Thank you for covering this.
Thank you very much.